alexis poulain éditorialise bonsoir et
merci d'être avec nous autres et pulvar
i gérald darmanin qui portent plainte
l'un contre l'autre en pleine campagne
pour les élections régionales régionales
une simple coïncidence bien sûr oui sans
doute non c'est clairement malheureux ça
montre finalement l'inanité du débat
politique où on en vient à utiliser la
justice comme un faire-valoir pour faire
monter ou descendre un candidat sur des
bases totalement fallacieuse est ce le
rôle d'un ministre de l'intérieur de
manifester avec des policiers non ce
n'était déjà pas le cas est ce le rôle
ensuite d'un ministre de l'intérieur de
porter plainte pour les propos d'une
responsable politique en campagne non
plus c'est totalement déplacées et
personne dans ce gouvernement pour
recadrer gérald darmanin et lui dire
qu'il devrait s'occuper de l'insécurité
s'occupait également des forces de
police et de leurs revendications
on est là dans une campagne politicienne
où la justice est totalement
instrumentalisée et audrey pulvar l'a
compris d'ailleurs qu'est ce qu'elle
fait elle utilise exactement l'effet
boomerang l'effet streisand en disant eh
bien puisque gérald darmanin m'attaque
c'est à mon tour de contre-attaquer en
l'attaquant à son tour pour diffamation
ça n'ira nulle part ce sont des plaintes
totalement ubuesque c'est du temps perdu
c'est surtout assez grave pour le climat
politique parce que ça montre que la
liberté de parole est de plus en plus
encadré plus en plus contraintes y
compris pour des responsables politiques
qui ont quand même assez une assez
grande latitude pour prendre la parole
notamment en temps de campagne
électorale donc c'est un précédent qui
ne doit pas être pris à la légère parce
que ça voudrait dire que demain
n'importe quel candidat pourrait être
accusée par un ministre de diffamation
ou autres et être souffrir de procédure
bayon le fameux lot faire à la façon
dont la justice peut être
instrumentalisée par le pouvoir en place
pour empêcher les opposants de montella
en l'occurrence ce n'est pas le cas ça
fait beaucoup de publicité pour audrey
pulvar elle doit dire merci gérald
darmanin
ça permet dans la dernière ligne droite
de la campagne des régionales de la
positionner clairement comme une
candidate de gauche face à un ministre
de droite ministre des manèges mâcon qui
mélange les genres sans jamais comme je
le disais être recadré par l'exécutif
on comprend l'intérêt d'audrey pulvar
quel est le but poursuivi en revanche
par le ministre
de l'intérieur a signé une candidate au
silence comme le déclare l'avocat
d'audrey pulvar non parce que lunel bien
sûr qu'elle n'est pas assigné au silence
est elle réelle répliqué au contraire
c'est pour elle un porte voix formidable
non je crois que la manoeuvre pour
gérald darmanin ces deux prolongé la
séquence de la manifestation des
syndicats policiers devant l'assemblée
nationale où ça s'est très mal passé
pour lui il pensait reconnecter avec la
base en étant parmi les manifestants il
s'est fait lui ça a été un fiasco
donc là il essaye de raccrocher les
wagons avec les syndicats policiers qui
avaient demandé à ce que ses propos
soient soient sanctionnés par le
ministre don qu'il obéit aux syndicats
il est dans une course finalement pour
montrer combien il va tout faire pour
satisfaire les demandes des syndicats
est resté en place et être un ministre
aimait de ses troupes
même si c'est loin d'être le cas donc
pour lui la manoeuvre est clairement
politique gérald darmanin pense déjà au
coude après qu'est ce qu'il fera après
beauvau il faut qu'il sorte par le haut
avec des bons chiffres avec aussi un
bilan positif et des policiers qui
trouveront qu'il a été un bon ministre
de l'intérieur parce que fait gérald
darmanin
eh bien ils copient il marche dans les
pas de son maître de son mentor nicolas
sarkozy qui a été à miss de l'intérieur
et mais à l'époque par par les policiers
même si il a il avait fait beaucoup de
mesures qui maintenant sont critiqués
par la police donc on est là vraiment
dans une manoeuvre politicienne à somme
nulle parce que je ne crois pas que
gérald darmanin va en retirer
immédiatement les bénéfices en
l'occurrence ils se ridiculisent plutôt
avec 7 contre plainte d'une candidate
aux régionales alors que lui est
ministre et qu'il a bien d'autres choses
à faire dans cette fonction régalienne
alors qui est le plus à perdre dans
cette passe d'armes selon vous gérald
darmanin comme vous semblez l'expliquer
oui clairement pour moi c'est lui qui
perd un peu de sa stature régaliennes
qui perd aussi de sa fonction
ministérielle à rentrer dans une
politique politicienne pour des
régionales on n'est même pas sûr un
enjeu national donc on se demande qu'est
ce qu'il va faire dans cette galère
d'une certaine façon à part comme je
viens de le dire essayer de satisfaire
les syndicats policiers les rassurer et
gagner du temps à la tête du ministère
de l'intérieur mais pour lui
c'est pas une manoeuvre qui va forcément
lui être bénéfique dans l'immédiat
contrairement à dre pulvar qui elle va
pouvoir surfer en sur cette étiquette de
candidates montré du doigt ou attaqués
par le ministre de l'intérieur sur
d'ailleurs des fallacieux motif je ne
pense pas que la justice ira très loin
dans cette affaire c'est vraiment de la
posture et ça montre qu'on est en train
de passer de la politique spectacle à un
triste spectacle de la politique est une
fois de plus le ps qui soutient tout de
même sa candidate coûte que coûte un oui
c'est normal on ne va pas changer de
candidat toutes les listes ont été
déposées donc audrey pulvar est la
candidate investie par le ps il va
falloir la soutenir coûte que coûte même
si on sent bien les contorsions et
parfois les gênes 1 du côté de la maire
de paris anne hidalgo qui a pris ses
distances qui est revenu audrey pulvar
elle est assez nouvelle dans ce jeu
politique elle a fait quelques erreurs
elle continue d'étonner dans le paysage
politique avec des déclarations qui
parfois peuvent sembler choquant pour
ses camarades du parti socialiste
mais le choix a été fait elle est la
candidate en ile de france elle va donc
aller jusqu'au bout et le ps va devoir
la soutenir et en l'occurrence c'est
plutôt bénéfique d'avoir cette plainte
du ministre comme je le disais en termes
d'audimat en termes d'audience de
visibilité ça permet de la mettre sur le
devant sans même parler du programme que
défend le parti socialiste pour la
région ile de france
merci alexis poulain